you're watching the GameSpot co-op stage
sponsored by Lego Star Wars The Force
awakens
what's the approach like Simeon pays for
some that way let me know continuing
coverage of a 3 2016 drum I'm here with
Sam pal Liam Liam O'Brien
2nd most higher standing person thank
you so much for going on for the past 90
minutes to talk to us we're actually
live on geek and sundry as well right
now so operators chat and this is the
perfect opportunity for them because
we're basically doing QA right we're
trying it out yeah we pulled a couple of
questions I think you pulled a couple of
course I got some here might almost
think from the Saudi gamespot crowd
we've got questions about like voice
acting goin on okay your questions are
sort of like into the critical role and
indeed yeah you want to tip T us off
sure about that Ashley Johnson plaid
there yeah right there that's just press
right at your last of us planned Laura
is not a happy mom thank you let's get
the ball rolling Craig danbury asking
what was the hardest role you have ever
played as a voice act for who wants to
take y'all go yeah hardest one that I
did was Gollum and shadow of Mordor
right because it's it's you know it's
tricky on the chords but I also did all
the performance capture for it so I had
to I had to hold the whole time while
running around like a spider monkey
yeah and climbing on all fours down fake
mountain metal boxes basically so
between every take you know what my teen
years are long ago so it takes I just be
let's go again let's go again but I
would do it I would do it again in a
heartbeat
yeah vocally I mean I played Starscream
in a couple games and that's
they're not fun but I think the most
intimidating moment I was doing motion
capture for one of the spider-man games
and I had to jump off like a 12 foot
high thing and tackle a woman okay and I
went up to her I was like oh I don't
want to hurt you
oh yeah and she she was this big stunt
woman and she's like you can't hurt me
and she's like try and so I was very
tight tried it did nothing to her it was
very emasculating for right you jumping
off a building on
yeah and off like a 12-foot high riser
and just tackle her as hard as I can and
she got up and she was just like that
did nothing to me didn't feel it again
yeah
cameras aren't even on anymore motion
caps off in the street do it again well
it's one of those things that looks
great in the game but if you actually
see people doing it it basically looks
like scuba men playing at Gymboree it's
a little syllable on that level put that
stuff in the special features yeah what
about yourself though I distressfully
Blanca is the most stressful thing I can
only do like 1 hour shifts Riya goes out
right yeah and it's everything's loud
everything's yelled and everything's all
in the throat and that's just awful
monster man he's monster man any time
you do monster it's gonna be rough but
uh and then yes thumb work is far more
taxing than act acting is fun and
intense and great but like stunt work of
any kind is always how often is not in
their part of the deal it's not becoming
like increasingly part of your old yeah
if you're one of the central characters
on a triple a and there's performance
then yeah I mean they'll have a they'll
have stunt actors people are highly
trained more than us yeah they take
Falls and stuff although occasionally
they'll want the actor that they've
hired for the role to do it right for
Gollum I walked away with a
grapefruit-sized welt on the inside of
my leg just from not even from scenes
but from doing like the locomotion right
so normally you know Troy Baker just
kind of walks coolly across the I had to
sort of gorilla okay and every time like
need a thigh need a thigh bump and it
was there for a week I was so proud of
it was that a strange experience because
you're also like sort of jumping into
the shoes of Andy Serkis who would like
sort of defined what that was for people
yeah able to put your own mark on it or
was it like I think I mean I've been in
love with him yeah I've been in love
with Gollum since I was a kid right and
it's starting with the book then the
animated version of The Hobbit that came
out a long time ago so I've been
obsessed I'd like I'd like to think so
but Andy and the animators designed the
car right they lent me the keys for the
weekend and there was the best ride ever
I remember you doing that voice before
you booked that that guy used to do that
voice all the time no one will ever hire
me to do this yeah no oh you had it yeah
you had it in a can when when the call
came then yeah that's good stuff I have
a question that is critical role related
from at beckster Hulk face who says how
long and how extensive is your out of
game prep for fights against the big
baddies okay well this is a new thing
because we've only just been fighting
big big big bad yeah but in game we will
we will only ever prepare for a fight
offline off the stream if there's some
sort of justification for it in the game
like walking into the cab DAC fights
this is their fellow spoilers
yeah oh sorry which who knows how it
went
there was a long approach there was a
long walk and so we said okay during
that walk we probably would have planned
right and so between the weeks between
the the show weeks we had an epic
texting battle going on god it was all
of us saying well what are you gonna do
what am I gonna do I don't know what are
gonna do what you'll be the bottle-cap
you're the little snake you're gonna go
up the middle you do this you do that
but then if there's a situation where
like if you're in the belly of a large
creature I'd rather be able to talk to
your party no planning no planning yeah
but we were outside of that situation
planned separately away from you guys
and then kind of set our own thing
because we had like two minutes of what
are we gonna do and we'd sent we spent
two minutes just going okay this this
this done alright good and if we plan
as much as badly and as long as we did
via text on the show it would be the
worst show Oh No no one wants to see
they're a bunch of terrible ideas for
hours and hours an hour and then we pick
one terrible idea and we go with it
that's great yeah
any other questions should we road yeah
yeah Johnny goes I think I've got
another one
rotate everyone okay I got one more
question from the from the critical role
crowd the critter crowd quick uh-oh
where to go
someone is asking what it was like
designing your scrying spell for the
show for anyone who doesn't know Sam
plays a gnome bard on the show who can
leave a magical poop places and peer
through the poop so we do I want to look
behind the curtain well I you know we
play our game very late at night and
sometimes there's drinking involved so a
few times I may have OOP tin the game
and after my third or fourth poop I
started thinking maybe I should come up
with a reason for this so I called Matt
and and we it just took an hour to
figure out how it would work but I I
drink a potion the potion makes my poop
magical and I can see through it which
is really it's the gift that keeps on
giving
what type of things you see on the
toilet in places like open a tres you've
got a high vantage point
oops a jar like a lantern it's really
it's really my my calling card at this
price all right we're gonna switch out
us which way right we're gonna hop it
roll people
pull pull roll for all thank you girl
acting tech team Oh about sobbing Liam
thank you so much hello Brad questions
hi you have your own questions do you
all one of my questions no do we have
questions is this mic on oh hey
Marisha has all the question I do have
questions I betcha culprit currently um
they're on top of theirs the rest of us
just kind of sit there and have some
work I just hope I don't
we ask questions that Liam just asked as
I go well was it a bad poop no no it I
mean I'm assuming that was a Sam
question yeah a few of these I also
screencap that are for Matt okay here's
a good one this is from at doll
delusional great okay with the name hot
named Lucian align or battle you retired
go back and do over and why alright I
for one it's not a do over anything like
that I just wasn't able to be there for
the battle with the briar woods right
with chalice ins character Percy's sort
of whole storyline and that's something
that I wish I could have been there for
do you have work
yeah man stupid work gets in the way how
do you how do you frame that within the
the the fiction of the universe that
you're like not there I I just there's a
deep sadness that's there but it
actually worked out in the storyline
Matt set it up like it worked out right
during this time that we went she was a
cleric and we got to her temple of her
deity right and she was there to help
clean the temple up and take care of it
and she had to say goodbye to us and it
was so sad and then and then she can pop
in and be like this ethereal form of Pi
game it's amazing yeah every every once
in a while she comes to us it's like a
glowing vision and that's that's pretty
cool right you could just write around
all this stuff yeah yeah max I mean I
was really good at it yeah it's like
science fiction it's like why how are
these bullets working it's like he
invented the clam of the flam there's
like it's good thing we did that
Bama flam yeah yeah something I would
have done over again is the the last big
battle we just had with Roy a dragon no
spoilers that's why yeah sorry all right
but I rolled really really bad on my
final attack what did you roll better
what's wrong with what is wrong with me
but if I I saw must both my attacks oh
no I'm the next person that hit him
killed him Oh
I would have freaking rolled better I
probably would have gotten to kill the
dragon that's painful I mean the same
thing happened when we did our battle
royale and you I got you down to four
hit points and it's like had I just
rolled a little bit better but to be
fair I wouldn't have had it any other
way like that was that was a good way to
it come down to the very very bitter
hand between cleric and druid support
another hot question I got all right get
one from my pool from the games watch
out Lisa Owens asking it do you guys
ever like pitch to like games you want
to be in we're just talking to Liam
about the hole golem thing he always
wanted to do that and then it kind of
worked out wavy I didn't ask him if
maybe he greased the wheels with the
people there about that but if you guys
ever done that you ever been like yeah
you know what I really like to be in
uncharted I'd really like to be in you
know and just get yourself in there make
those connections III is on right now
maybe that's what you should be doing I
don't make games I don't think no if you
know that hard cuz you want to be cool
yeah you want to be cool man yeah so we
that and I think at the end of the day
when you book a role because of a good
audition right that's gonna make you
feel better than what you like yeah and
then you bribe them but I mean there's
also probably been a few times in my
life where I've been like I'd really
like to work on that yeah okay bye but
for the most part not a whole lot I
don't know I'd say the same I feel like
I would want to audition but I would I
think because I'm so obsessed with the
series I would want to do something with
portal right yes I don't even know what
that would even be because there aren't
really any dude I don't know I did a I
got a VR game with valve and it was in
the portal universe and it was so much
fun
but like to actually do a portal portal
game would be phenomenal I did when I
started working with telltale the first
thing I ever did was wolf among us
that audition came through I was like
okay yeah I totally want audition for
this but I had heard that they were
gonna do a game of Thrones game right
yeah yeah it was like I really want to
do a good audition for wolf so that I
could get in on Game of Thrones and I
talked about it in almost every session
like she was guys it sure would be nice
if this stuff was ready mercy think any
games out now you'd like to be in oh I
can think about ton of games I'd love to
be I want to be in all the games all the
time
okay buy it right all right we need to
get we need to go Eric we need Erik
Wolpaw to make a new portal so you can
all be in it there you go
what up there you go we can little bit
we can tell you Ashley she left her
phone we're gonna take some questions
from the audience I think anybody will
answer a question yes honey I'm has some
questions I'm at Mercer what was your
favorite magic item they've ever made
what does it do and why is it your
favorite my favorite magical item ever
made what does it do and why is my
favorite I'm probably going to lean
towards a weapon known as Craven edge
that's come up in the campaign
previously partially because it had been
a long time so I made a sentient weapon
and for those who know that it's a
weapon that actually has a personality
and a goal and a drive and it and it was
found by Travis's characters favorite
toy yeah but then it kind of did bad
things and made him do bad things and it
was like the best buddy comedy ever
between something that wasn't actually a
person so sad that I had to go but it
worked for the character arc and I think
if it it stayed around a little badass
weapon it was a badass I wish it hadn't
killed me still exist out there
it's in some extraterrestrial plane or a
serial plane or some sort of plane
that's what allows you to play a
character than in a way right because
you're informing what this character is
doing yeah like your voice within the
world yeah yeah he'll be like walking
into an area and all of a sudden this
sword will start speaking into his mind
he's like yes
kill them all
oh one another question Liam has some
questions also oh you don't
oh you text question no but I have a
question nobody from at stories and
dreams do you plan or interpersonal look
to our planet or personal interaction of
the head at all
for instance fax what fax is gonna say
to Kiel is what grogg gonna say to him I
don't know we do not interpersonal leo
only we had died me during the week
before the game if we wanted to know I
mean we we know each other and are
friends with each other and I'm sure our
friendships and relationships with each
other
bleed into the characters a little bit
but but no way no it's not it's not
written or planned we just kind of go
with our hearts and any other parts of
our body that you make decisions for I
think part of the fun too is surprising
or other players this is kind of you
know it's that that kind of idea of
improv of throwing someone else can
under the bus on stage in a way or like
oh so what do you think you know and
dragging them out of spotlight or seeing
their reactions so I know it plus a part
of the real fun of the game is not they
want to script anything you kind of
write it as it comes this game of improv
we just try and actually there are times
where we may throw each other like for a
loop and everybody hangs on sort of
wiping off of each other and like
feeling that energy I mean that's what
makes it such compelling live viewing as
well because you feel like you're like
really watching real moments that are
happening and it's not they are
surprised we can spend like half an hour
in between doing anything important at
all just because we're talking to each
other yeah I got a question here okay
you're gonna take it actually no one I'm
gonna use these Owens this question for
the last one because that was pretty
cool do you ever pitch to games that you
love are there any games out there that
like you wanted to be in and you were
kind of like you know what like pitch
ourselves as an actor or a story idea or
as an actor oh yeah how about that time
you dressed up in the Cirque du Soleil
outfit you did the the ribbon hanging
sure you know I usually send myself in a
box like in a package big different
developers on a faux pas cave I'll open
it up it's stinky cuz I've been in there
for days
but I'm like I'm the guy no I customized
to what the game is are there any like
developers who do you like you feel like
you I would love to work with them like
you got to work a blizzard recently yeah
yeah not like we've worked with them
before as well yeah but are there any
like you know developers that you've got
really like to see or you purged from
one of your colleagues that they're
really good to work for
there are plenty developers have a been
a fantastic III I'd the pleasure of
working on the dev aside before I became
an actor so I knew a lot of people and
that process beforehand but me like as
far as games it's one of those things we
have to write a line you you can't
really pitch yourself like out in the
open or do like a public calling cuz ya
can come across the wrong way you know a
lot of us who train the proper way you
kind of want to go through the proper
channels go through the auditioning
channels and if they if you're right for
the part they'll pick you but you know
if we're at a party like a post e3 party
drinking with so-and-so who worked on a
series that we love we'd be like hey if
you guys are ever doing the sequel I
love to be that one miniseries I'm a
creamy decent man
my hope I'm so glad overwatch is doing
well because I hope that they can begin
pushing into other forms of media right
like overwatch makes for a great video
game I think it also makes for a great
series the animated shorts they've been
working I love more that yeah when did
you record that stuff we recorded most
we began recording a year and a half ago
on that guys I mean then a bunch of
updates since then so yeah yeah it's
crazy stuff another way if you guys are
playing overwatch if you're if you ever
doing the level where the payload is the
the big old car that drives through the
movie lot and the guy in the car is
yelling at you oh really yeah
is that you I'm that jerk nice that's me
he's most jerks in most games to some
people I really have to stretch to
become a jerk and now in real life I'm
like a saint
yeah like the nicest print now I'm an
[ __ ] give any more questions on that
one I was only given the one question I
guess another question this sort comes
up a lot whenever I talk to like some of
you guys and because voice actors are
becoming you're becoming so visible like
you've becoming something we laura up on
this stage for like like so many like
before not just familiar voices but
familiar faces as well it's not like a
double edged sword we're like you know I
talked to Troy Baker about a couple of
months back where it's like after a
while like I've you ever exhaust your
range and people like are able to figure
out who
you are is that ever like a problem I
mean it's a concern it started to say if
it's a problem or not you know as this
performer is we can only do so much as
an actor than what we can do and if
we're lucky enough to work a lot you try
and make sure that you expand and
differentiate your performances best
your ability has become more popular
especially with a lot of facial motion
capture and scanning which make either
partial base for that then it becomes a
little more difficult because it can't
have the same face as the you know
character in every game it's always a
challenge to try and stretch your range
you know even if they are using your
face doing a different personality is
the same sort of challenge in a film or
an on-camera actor has yeah so if there
are some people like and there are
people that can pick out your voice very
easily in games but we just consider
them fans we appreciate that like the
majority of people who aren't able to
like I had no idea you are McCree and I
played like hundreds of hours of oh
watch it's working it's working yes we
don't even pick it out sometimes like
Sam played Starscream in the
Transformers game yeah yeah I had no
idea when I heard their record like oh
that's Sam yeah that's that's my second
voice I have two voices that one and me
talking thank you so much for coming on
thank you so much everyone
I critical role for coming on yeah they
really did it enjoy the rest of me three
you as well and yeah hopefully we'll see
you in the next coming months or maybe
at next year's show as well yeah for
tonight I think you all so much for
watching today's show on GameSpot on our
twitch on our GameSpot comm on our
YouTube thank you so much to all the
critters and the geeky sundry chat as
well that we really appreciate it we
will see you later on here I guess
there's more stuff happening yeah I was
I'm going upstairs to do more demos I
don't know what's on next bunch of
beautiful Bieber talking about video
games stick around
yeah
you